diese Paste hat es verdient genauso
bekannt zu sein wie Bolognese oder
Carbonara und sie heißt aller matriciana
und ich sage euch so viel die Pasta hat
wirklich in sich wir fangen an indem wir
unsere schneiden ich habe hier eine
wunderschöne guantschale wow wir
entfernen jetzt die Rinde den Speck
schneiden wir jetzt in grobe Würfel und
die geben wir jetzt in die Pfanne wir
haben ja schon richtigen swimming pool
ausgewandschale Fett und das wird uns so
viel Geschmack für die Pasta geben jetzt
fischen wir unsere Guan Schale
rauslassen das Fett in der Pfanne zurück
zum Fett geben wir die passierten
Tomaten
eine Zutaten fehlt noch eine chili
halbieren so gehen wir jetzt dazu jetzt
Köche Qualitätskontrolle boah schon gut
Nudeln sind fertig wir geben sie in die
Pasta bisschen Pecorino dran das ist
eine klassische hirtenpasta deshalb
Schafskäse gonschale der haltbar war und
nicht viel mehr Runde zwei
und gegebenen Schale wieder dazu es gibt
nicht genug Käse wow
probieren wir